Let's come back to the formula.
to calculate the first mean
Excuse me to calculate the first moment.
To calculate the first moment of the population.
in other words the mean the population mean
you are going to calculate the first moment. So the population
mean how do you get it by calculating the first moment these they're the
same thing.
And that means you take the sum.
e to the power
T times x sub 1 times the probability
let me quickly tell you why we have
e
okay.
for the four moments
standard deviation kurtosis
skewness
and mean we are going to use a sample listen
to this keyword to estimate.
parameters of the population
moments of the population
in mathematics
There are four levels of estimation. There are four
ways. You can estimate.
Number one is using guesstimate.
Just doing numbers in your head.
Then you have Lee polynomials.
Linear polynomial for example, is this second best way to guess a
number?
The fourth level is using something called McLaren series.
The formula for calculating moments whether it
is a discrete random variable or a continuous random variable.
The best way to do an estimation is to do McLaren series.
Okay, so I'm just putting this out. So, you know
that the letter e this this one
single character is talking.
is this
can be computed this way ease, of course Euler's
number.
which is an irrational number but
Another way you can compute all is never is.
Usually my clouds use which is a type of Taylor series.